Ya
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
anne ben birinci nasıl bir genç kız
olacağım bu benim Küçükken annemle vakit
geçirirken aynanın karşısında oturdum
kendime Bak Ardına ona sürekli bu soruyu
sorardım acaba güzel bir kadın
olabilecek miydim başarılı ayakları yere
basan O dergilerdeki
televizyonlardaki kadınlar gibi
olabilecek miydim ben kendim ince ince
yapılı uzun boylu esmer ve kızdım ama
genellikle insanlar beni zayıf cılız
kara kuru güçsüz olarak tanımlar dıb
an iyice büyümeye başladıktan sonra bir
fark ettim ki ben arkadaşlarım gibi
değilim
bu Hem onlar gibi düşünmüyorum hem de
onlar gibi de değilim kolum bacağım uzun
uzamaya başladı bir farklılık var yani
Bunu
ister istemez fark etmeye başladım
zamanla bu farklılıkların benim için bir
dezavantajı dönüşmeye başladı Bunu size
şöyle örneklemek istiyorum ve Mesela bir
gün İngilizce hocamın Benim asla
İngilizce öğreneceğim ve buna yeteneğim
olmadığını söyledi çok üzülmüştüm
gerçekten İngilizce yoklar seviyordum ki
ya da bir gün bir arkadaşımın annesi
benim sadece boyum olduğu için birtakım
da voleybol oynayabildiği mi Hatta
arkadaşımın benden daha yetenekli olup
onun yerini aldığını söylemişti şimdi ya
da başka bir örnek vereyim çok uzun
boylu olduğu için hep en arka sıraya
oturdum vardı bir de dersi dinlemediğim
için dikkatini aldığı için beni
başarısız olmakla suçlarlar the sizde
videonun çocukluğumuza bir hatır var ya
böyle koskocaman yetişkinler olduğumuzda
bile aklımıza gelir böyle
çocukluğumuzdan kalan birkaç cümle
birkaç insanın söylediği şeyler hep
böyle aklınıza kazanır bu onları tekrar
hatırladığımız zaman ya o da neydi öyle
deriz
ben zamanla baktım insanlara adapte
olamıyorum bu sisteme adapte olamıyorum
dedim Okey Tamam madem farklıyım o zaman
kendi istediğim gibi farklı bir çocuk
olacağım onların istediği gibi değil
Saçlarımı kestirdim farklı bir tarzda
büründüm farklı müzikler dinledim iki
aykırı bir çocuk oldum hani böyle
dersiniz yokuda bu çocuğa ne oldu böyle
bir anda değişiverdi o çocukları bunlar
oluyor işte haksızlık ediliyor şu
kendileri oldukları için kendileri gibi
düşündükleri için
bu
ve bu dönemde de lise sınav stresi
başladı mı Herkes çok stresli Ebeveynler
stresli arkadaşlar streste herkesin
sizden bir beklentisi var çünkü size
deniyor ki eğer iyi bir şey Giremezsen
İyi bir üniversiteye giremez İyi bir
üniversiteye Giremezsen iyi bir işin
kapısını açamaz ve böylece sizi böyle
bir tekerleğin içine alıp yuvarlamaya
başlıyorlar
ve bu tamamen bir yalan Ben bunu
büyüdükçe kendi kendime kanıtladım ve
yaşım ne gerektiriyorsa Ben onları
yapmayı tercih ettim insanlar bana
başarısızsın dedi ama ben başarılı
kendimi ölçmek istedim insanların elinde
bırakmadım
zamanda Ben büyümeye başladım artık lise
sonra geldiğimde iyice kendimi
törpülenmiş Team İyice böyle
nasıl biri olmak istediğim ideallerine
yapmak istediğimi ben kendim karar
vermeye başlamıştım ama yani çok da
popüler bir kız olamıyorum Yani hep bir
sorun harbi yerden bir sıkıntı çıkıyor
ya çok zayıf oluyorum ya çok esmer
oluyorum hep böyle takılan bi lakaplar
var
bu Neyse bir gün dershaneden eve
dönüyorum
arkadaşımı biri geldi beni durdurdu
karşıma geçti sen kimsin Ya
ben Günce modellik yapıyor musun sen
Herkes sana bakıyor sen tanımlamıyor
misin Hayır dedim tanımıyorum ben 17
yaşında üniversiteye hazırlanıyorlar ben
dedi Yetenek Avcısı ve modelleri sokakta
keşfediyorum O delik yapmayı düşünür
müsünüz tabi dedim Neden olmasın yani
hangi genç kızın Hayır diyebilir ki on
tamam dedim sonra ailemle konuştum
kontrat süresini inceledik bir baktık
beş senelik bir kontrat hiç akla yatkın
değil
tamam model olmak istiyorum ama kendimi
de böyle bir yere bağlamak istemiyorum
hep özgür olmak istiyorum okey Bu da
olmadı anne ailem dedi ki o zaman git
Türkiye'de tanınmış insanlarla tanış o
insanlardan bir fikir a gittim tanıştım
hepsi çok iyi çok tatlı insanlar ama bir
türlü Kafamdaki o
görseline o uyduramadım bir türlü yapmak
istediğim şey Onlar da değildi başka bir
yerdeydi Ama bu sırada ben çok sevdiğim
Özlem Üniversitesi'ne girmiş oldum hem
de burslu bir şekilde girmiş oldum
okula gidiyorum geliyorum Bu sırada bir
ajanstan bana Instagram'dan mesaj geldi
abi Günce modellik yapıyor musun
modellik yapmak ister misin yani Şans
Kapıyı daha fazla çalamadı halde ben de
bu saf halini Evet yapmak istiyorum
gittim görüştüm Bir baktım gerçekten
yapmak istedim Yapmak istediklerimi bu
acımasız gerçekten sahip
süper dedim modellik yapmaya başladım
ilk başta kimse böyle bir Emin olamadı
Türk mü model mi yapabilir mi gerçekten
E tabi birtakım algılar var bu güzellik
algıları bu beğeniler bunu yıkmak çok
zor
Ben de dedim ki pes etmeyeceğim bir gün
olacak bu günlerde yavaş yavaş gelmeye
başladı birkaç tane tasarımcı beni
beğendi işte para da kazanmaya
Başlıyorum her şey yolunda gitmeye
başladı bu ve bu sırada üniversitede
işte hocaları söylüyorum diyorum ki işte
a Çünkü Anadolu yakasından Avrupa
yakasına gitmem gerekiyor 3 saat yol
çekiyorum Bir sürü böyle
seçmenlerle uğraşıyorum defileler için
Neyse bir gün İşte o hocalarıma
soruyorum hocalarım da işte birisi diyor
ki Oha ne kadar güzel ve Unique bir şey
yapıyorsun mutlaka git ben sana izin
veriyorum bir ne yaptığımı anlayamıyor
böyle bakıyor enteresan diyor bir
hocamın da istediğini unutmuyorum gün
cicim Benim için sorun değil ancak
tecrübeyle sabit ki okumayla çalışmak
aynı anda olmaz
bilmem ben burada bir parantez açmak
istiyorum üniversiteye girdiğiniz İlk
seneden itibaren
bir işe girin ve çalışın Ne olduğunun
hiçbir önemi yok Her ne olursa olsun
çünkü sosyal hayattaki becerilerinizi
Siz bu yaşlarda tamamlamaya
başlıyorsunuz bu yaşlarda kendinizi
gelir bu elimde dönem leriniz gerçekten
Bunun hepsini ortalama kasmak için heba
etmeye değer mi akademik bir kaygınız
varsa Ortada hiçbir şey söylemiyorum ama
sizin deneyimleriniz o kadar önemli ki
Siz mezun olduktan sonra bunlar Siz
Aslında 1-0 öne geçirecek şeyler yer
Neyse gel zaman git zaman ben bir
şekilde okula boğuşuyorum casting lerle
boğuşuyorum seçmenlerle bir gün bir
seçmeye çağırıldım
şu Bayağı da uzun bir yol gittim çok da
hastayım İçeri girer girmez bana Dediler
ki gün cc1 seni saçma yapacağız tabii ki
saygı duyarım Çünkü bizim meslekte her
model hal koleksiyonu ya da her
tasarımcı uyuyacak diye bir şey yok İyi
tamam dedim Teşekkür ettim tam arkamı
dönerken Ha bu arada bu kiloyla devam
edersen seni hiçbir şey oldu
çıkarmayacağız dediler bana
döndüm Tamam dedim o zaman iş yerimi
bilgilendirin Ajansı mı Ben dedim üç
saat yol gelmek zorunda kalmama
ayrıyeten dedim sadece İstanbul mu var
yani New York Londra Milano Paris saçını
yüklenen oldu ki
olmadı dedim Onları giderim yani Ama
istemiyorsanız gerçekten söyleyin de ben
bu kapıyı aşındırmak Tan bir Vazgeçtim
artık
ben o gün o kapıdan dışarı adım
attığımda bugün burada bu konuşmayı
yapmamızı sağlayacak adımı Amerika'ya
atmış oldum bir kıta uzağa
Amerika'ya gittim orada bir ajansla
anlaştım yaklaşık bir altı ay kadar
orada kaldım New York Fashion Week de de
yürüdüm ama modellik istediğim gibi
gitmedi Tamam dedim hiç problem yok
üniversiteye dönerim ya beyaz yakalı var
ya bir girişim evi start-up başlatırım
ya sonuçta Yapabileceğin şeylerin sonu
yok Yani illa model olmak istedin diye
model olmak zorundasın ya da model
olabilecek misin diye bir şey yok neyse
ben İstanbul'a döndüm bir ara verdim
sonra çok beğendiğim dergilerden
Türkiye'de biri bana mesaj at Senin
çekim yapmak istiyoruz diye Ah sizin
süper o çekimde Ben bir model ya
tanıştım bana ajansının ve menajerinin
ne kadar iyi olduğunu ona çok güzel
işler ayarladığını ve bir de çok çok çok
güzel kızlarla çalıştın söyleyince Tabi
ben bir adım geri attım çünkü Ya bir
insan kendine böyle güzel demeye
çekiliyor aslında
Neyse zaman geçti birkaç tane daha
gelmeye başlayınca Tamam dedim ben bu
işi gerçekten yurtdışına taşıyacağım
birkaç tane menajerle daha konuşmaya
başladım işler istediğim gibi bu
gitmiyor yani vizyonumuz tutmuyor sonra
kütüphanede oturuyorum bir anda aklıma
geldi Ah dedim böyle bir menajer vardı
hemen kızım Ajansı'nın sitesine girdim
Tamam ben info kısmına bakarken bir
baktım menajerinin Email adresi orada
duruyor rhaast dedim süper bizim
favorilerimiz vardır modellerin 4
kareden oluşur böyle portren iz bir
boydan bir kaç tane cool fotoğrafınız
olur neyse o
Polo iplerimi ben gönderdim Bir an Ajans
arıyorum dedim ve bana Yardımcı olmanızı
istiyorum çünkü ama ajanslar sizin 78
farklı ülkede hem size oradaki
ajanslarla anlaşma sağlar hem de sizin
haklarınızı korurlar
ve Neyse ben Bilgisayarı kapattım
135 adım attım kütüphaneden tam
çıkıyorum Bir anda mesaj geldi
güncel bir seni çok beğeniyoruz ne zaman
hamur gelebilirsin dedim bu Okey beş gün
var Beş gün sonra finallerin bitiyor
teklemeden finallerini verdim o kadar
çok çalıştım ki kalmamak için Oradan
kalktım hamburger gittim işte dedim
Benim kendimi kanıtlamak gereken yer tam
olarak burası içeri girdim
şey kendimi İngilizce'mi oturmamı kalkma
mı bu iş gerçekten yapabileceğim ve
yapmak istediğimi söyledim
Beni çok beğendiler ve beş gün içinde
stok Onu ilk işimi ayarladı lar ardından
Parti arkadaşlarını görmeye giderken bir
anda kendimi farz kötülükte yürürken
buldum derken ajansları dolaşmaya
başladım tarihte yani yüz yüze görüşmek
her zaman daha iyidir farz de birkaç
tane Ajansı görüşmesine girdim ondan
sonra Ajan Sen bana bir mail geldi Günce
biletini al ver lütfen evine dön
de
tamam dedim artık Demek ki olmuyormuş
Ben biletimi aldım Çok da mutsuzum
oturdum tüm gün günde ağlıyorum gözlerim
şişti artık
burada Mehmet abi telefonu sürekli
gülüyor bir anda telefonu aldım
biraz Gözüm karardı yani okuduğum şeyi
okudum ve Anladım
Muhtemelen Tansiyonum düştü ve telefon
geldi gün jaure Confort horb Valencia
gol vardı Ekspresi
Yani valensiaga benim bütün sezonu
kapatmıştı ve bu işareti koku elenmişti
yani ne Paris ne Milan ne Milano hiçbir
yerde başka bir defilede Yürüyemiyorum
Neyse bir buçuk ayın var Ben İstanbul'a
geldim bekliyorum Bekliyorum Bekliyorum
kimseye bir şey söylemiyorum
derken o bir buçuk ayın sonu geldi çattı
evden valiz mi aldım parça bu doğru yola
çıktım kimseye bir şey söylemiyorum Son
dakikaya kadar anneme bir şey söylemedim
ve ben Valencia kanın binasının içine
girer girmez Sıra bana geldiğinde içeri
adım attığımda bir anda kollarını açlar
günü Hoş geldin o kadar çok fotoğrafına
baktık ki en yakın arkadaşımız gibi oldu
neler ve kahkaha atmaya başladılar işte
dedim şimi işte Farklı olmamın
karşılığını bulduğum yer burasıydı
şıfa is başka bir yerde olabilirdi
bu şovun ardından çok mutluyum Tabii ki
Kariyerim inanılmaz bir ima al dünyanın
dört yanında farklı markalar çekimler ve
önemli insanlarla tanışma fırsatı buldum
marakeşten Paris'e Paris'ten kanarya
adalarına oradan Kuzey Rusya'ya uzanan
çılgın lokasyon çekimleri yaptım günü
Ben geldiğimde kendime dönüp bakıp dedim
ki güncel Evet
var yani o sıska karakuru hiçbir şey
yapamayan hiçbir şey hak etmediği
söylenen o kız artık bunu
yapmıştık kendini aldı işini aldı Sıkı
Sıkı tutun ve Global e taşıdı kendini
Ah ah dedim
Sonunda yaptım tabii ki iniş çıkışları
hiçbir zaman bitmedi zamanda bitmeyecek
bunu hepimiz farkındayız
bu ve biliyorum Bazen hepimiz Kendimizi
çok zor da çıkmaz da
bitmiş tükenmiş artık hiçbir şey
yapamayacak mış gibi hissediyoruz ama
görüyorsunuz yani vişne olması için kaç
tane Hayır yemek gerekiyor insanların
size Demek ki bazen hayırlı uğurlu
olması gerekiyor ki siz bir şeylerin
peşinde daha sıkı düşersiniz
ben şunu asla inanmıyorum insana hep
birileri birileri ile karşılaştırır ve
hep kendilerinden mutlu olmak için bir
sebep Arar nasıl parmak iziniz ve iri
siniz bir tane ise sizin güzelliğiniz de
zekanız da başarınız da kimseyle
karşılaştırılamayacak kadar özel bu
başarıların hepsini siz siz olduğunuz
için aldınız
bu kumarım bu konuşmam size yardımcı
olur herhangi zorlandığınız bir anda
Lütfen hayallerinizi kimsenin elinizde
almasına İzin vermeyin Ben bugün Aynanın
Karşısına geçeceğim ve bak bakalım nasıl
bir genç kadın olmuşsun diyeceğim beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
Çok sağ olun
[Alkış]